hi this is pressure Locker this puzzle
makes for a fun question to ask your
friends at parties and it's also used as
an interview question so imagine you
have ten coins and three cups your job
is to place the ten coins into the three
cups so that each cup contains an odd
number of coins give this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching the
video for the solution so I would
approach the question mathematically by
looking for the ways you can add three
numbers up to ten these are also known
as the partitions of 10 so you could
have 1 plus 1 plus 8 which equals 10 you
could also write this as 1 plus 8 plus 1
or 8 plus 1 plus 1 but I'm going to
write the sums in increasing order so I
don't have to write every single
possibility we'll come up with the
different ways that we can add three
numbers up to 10 and write them in
increasing order there are only a few
number of ways and what you'll notice in
every single possibility one of the
numbers at least one of the numbers will
be an even number so if we want to have
all three cups be odd numbers we
actually have an impossibility now just
in case I didn't write down all the
possibilities I'm going to prove this as
well so suppose we try and put an odd
number into each cup so we have 2x plus
1 2 I plus 1 and 2z plus 1 we want the
sum of the coins to equal 10 and that
means we have 2 times some number X plus
y plus Z equals 7 now clearly this is
going to be impossible because we can't
have 2 times a whole positive number be
equal to an odd number which is 7 so we
cannot solve this problem in the
traditional way by trying to partition
the 10 coins so that each cup has an odd
number of coins so we're going to have
to think creatively
so let's take one of the partitions two
three and five we'll put two coins into
the left cup three coins into the milk
up and we'll put five the remaining five
coins into the third cup so how can we
get all three cups to have an odd number
of coins well here's the trick we take
the middle cup and place it on top of
the first cup so now that middle cup
still has three coins that's an odd
number the first cup actually contains
two plus three coins which is five and
five is an odd number and the cup on the
right contains five so that also is an
odd number so this solution corresponds
to the partition of two three and five
which is one even number and two odd
numbers so we could similarly do this
solution whenever we have one even
number and two odd numbers we will put
the cup which has one of the cups which
has an odd number in one of the cups
which has an even number so with one one
and eight we would put one of the cups
which has one on top of one of the cup
which has eight so we can similarly do
this kind of solution whenever we have
one even number and two odd numbers now
if we have to if we have all even
numbers that's not going to generate us
a solution because an even plus and even
will still be an even we'd also expand
the solution so if we had zero one and
nine and then we put the cup with one in
side of the cup which has zero we'll
also get a solution where all the cups
have an odd number so if you expand zero
you also get a couple more solutions did
you figure it out thanks for watching
this video please subscribe to my
channel I make videos on math and game
theory you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions which you can follow on
Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
also catch me on social media at
pressure Locker now if you like this
video please check on my books there are
links in the video description